One of the most well-known characters in comic
book history, Superman is also one of the
oldest.
Created by writer Jerry Siegel and artist
Joe Shuster, Superman first appeared in Action
Comics number 1 – all the way back in June
of 1938, setting the stage for countless superheroes
that followed in the next seventy-eight years
(and counting).
While certain elements of Superman’s backstory
and powers remain the same nearly eight decades
later, different writers and artists also
brought with them changes to the hero’s
mythology.
Some carried forward, adding to Superman canon,
while others were set aside and abandoned
when they were no longer needed.
While there is not one “official” Superman,
though fans will likely have their favorites,
DC Comics has attempted to refine the Man
of Steel over the years – delving deeper
and deeper into why the Kryptonian hero can
do the various “super” things he does.
Superman’s powers are no secret but how,
exactly, science (albeit science fiction)
contributes to Kal-El’s super-human abilities
is less well-known.
This might be review for the biggest Superman
lovers but, for fans who want to know more
about the Big Blue Boy Scout, we’re digging
into the god-like biology of Earth’s iconic
Kryptonian for our latest docu series video:
the real science behind Superman’s coolest
powers.
Super Fuel
Originally, the reason for Superman's abilities
was not explicitly detailed – other than
stating Superman is an alien.
However, as the Superman character developed
over the years, DC writers attempted to provide
real world explanations for the hero's super
powers, settling on the idea that Superman
receives his abilities from stored-up solar
energy - via Earth's yellow sun.
Where Kryptonians lived under the harsh conditions
of a red sun, known as Rao, Superman's body
is able to metabolize energy from Earth’s
yellow sun (similar to how humans metabolize
energy from their food) - then uses that energy
to fuel his various super powers (with the
added benefit of slowing the kryptonian's
aging).
Like most life forms, Superman can also store
excess energy for later use – which is then
used to fuel many of Kal-El’s powers
However, the hero’s solar-powered abilities
also come with drawbacks.
Should the Kryptonian over-use his super powers,
without a chance to recharge, he can exhaust
all of his reserve energy - becoming weakened
and even vulnerable to injury.
Similarly, red sunlight has a similar effect
- blocking Kal-El’s ability to absorb yellow
sun and, consequently, suppressing his superhuman
abilities.
Of course, the opposite can be true as well.
In certain situations, Superman can even choose
to over-charge his cells with solar energy,
granting him enhanced healing and additional
abilities.
In particular, The Death of Superman saw Kal-El's
critically injured body returned to the Fortress
of Solitude and placed inside the regeneration
matrix to be rejuvenated - a feat that required
both the hero's inherent solar regeneration
and advanced Kryptonian technology.
Super Strength, Speed, and Perception
Initially described as "more powerful than
a locomotive and faster than a speeding bullet,"
Kal-El's super abilities have increased significantly
over the years.
Yet, Superman's strength, endurance, and speed,
are derived from stored solar energy - providing
fuel to his inherently dense molecular structure
- allowing Kal-El to move with superhuman
force (all without injury to himself).
Still, for that reason, Superman's raw power
is incalculable - since his strength and speed
is not a uniform benchmark and can be diminished
or amplified by other conditions and external
factors – especially the amount of solar
energy he has stored.
That energy also affords the Kryptonian enhanced
reflexes and a relative perception of time
- making him a dangerous hand-to-hand combatant.
This means that the Man of Steel can quickly
react to the actions of others as well as
assess his environment much quicker than humans.
This isn't to say that Superman necessarily
slows time or perceives normal time differently
than humans by default but, at the very least,
the hero is capable of heightened in-the-moment
focus, allowing him to rapidly process and
react to external stimuli.
One of Superman's most iconic super powers,
freeze breath might seem like an exception
to Kal-El’s solar-powered skill set; yet,
the super breath is actually an extension
of the hero’s strength - thanks to the real-life
Joule–Thomson effect.
The effect shows that compressed air, rapidly
pushed through a restricted opening rapidly
reduces the overall temperature of the burst.
This means Superman, who can forcefully exhale
at high velocity and pressure, could turn
the burst into an arctic blast - by intentionally
directing the air through pursed lips.
Bio-Electric Aura
Kal-El has only been shown to possess telekinetic
abilities on a few isolated occasions; however,
it is largely accepted that Superman’s store
of solar energy also affords him a bio-electric
aura that allows him to manipulate electromagnetic
fields – an ability that has come to be
known as “tactile telekinesis.”
Tactile telekinesis attempts to explain why
Superman can pick up a jetliner by the nose
without the entire airplane buckling from
the pull of gravity on the tail-end (for example)
- asserting that the hero was surrounded by
a solar-powered telekinetic aura that engulfed
anything he touched - resulting in both physical
and electromagnetic field manipulation to
evenly distribute force across an object through
only one point of contact.
Superman's "flight" was, originally, an extension
of his strength - as the super-strong hero
could just leap higher and farther than humans.
However, viewers who watched Zack Snyder’s
Man of Steel will see that jumping alone isn't
enough to keep Superman airborne (at least
in the modern movie universe); instead, Superman
is shown lifting and spinning ice particles
before erupting into the sky - implying that
he isn't just pushing off or jumping, he's
consciously using his bioelectric aura to
manipulating surrounding gravitational forces
– tactile telekinesis in practice.
In the film’s final fight, Zod is also shown
to levitate debris and other items when he
learns to fly – indicating that when Kryptonians
take flight, that flight unleashes energy
onto the surrounding area and objects.
As a result, the levitation seen in Man of
Steel is an example of a complex gravitational
field manipulation that allows Kryptonians
on Earth to outright defy gravity, hover above
the ground, and even lift heavy objects into
the sky – all thanks to repurposing of solar
energy.
Invulnerability
Certain versions of Superman also credit his
"bio-electric aura" as a contributor to the
hero’s invulnerability – as the bio-electric
aura also surrounds objects and organisms
in Superman's immediate vicinity, making it
possible for Kal-El to protect Lois Lane,
for example, from a deadly explosion without
having to cover every square inch of her body.
The strength and range of Superman's bio-electric
aura varies but, in an extreme case, enabled
the hero to survive a supernova.
Still, the even though justifications for
Kryptonian invulnerability can vary, most
have one thing in common: solar energy.
As previously detailed, Krypton's red sun
caused the kryptonians to evolve under extremely
harsh conditions, in comparison to Earth,
affording the extra-terrestrial race with
an extremely dense molecular structure - including
near-unbreakable cellular bonds.
For that reason, the Man of Steel is invulnerable
to injury on Earth - be it piercing, puncture,
impact, and incineration.
Still, absorbing yellow sun is necessary for
Superman to maintain this invulnerability
- as metabolized solar energy fuels and strengthens
those near-unbreakable cellular bonds.
If Kal-El depletes his solar stores or is
exposed to kryptonite materials, he becomes
increasingly vulnerable to attack and injury
as well.
Heat Vision
Since Superman's powers are derived by absorbing
and metabolizing solar energy then using that
energy to fuel super strength, speed, and
other enhanced abilities, one of the more
literal examples of this process is Superman's
heat vision - which allows the hero to emit
stored solar energy as directed beams of focused
heat through his eyes.
The beams have varied in precision and strength
throughout the years but have been shown to
reach objects over a hundred feet away and,
conversely, feature surgical accuracy - down
to microscopic levels.
Depending on the situation and intensity of
the emission, Superman's heat vision can be
invisible to the naked eye - allowing the
hero to use the power, albeit sparingly, even
when disguised as Clark Kent.
As indicated, Superman can also over-charge
with solar power, and in modern versions of
the character, a new evolution of heat vision
was introduced: the "super flare."
Using the same mechanics as heat vision, Superman
can unleash a devastating attack on his surrounding
environment - by venting the stored solar
energy in every single one of his cells.
The super flare is possibly the hero's most
powerful ability but comes with a downside
- expelling all of his stored up solar energy
leaves Kal-El vulnerable and without powers,
essentially human, for nearly 24 hours (the
time it takes him to recharge his solar stores).
Even though we didn’t cover all of Superman’s
powers here, it’s safe to say that many
of the hero’s stranger abilities can also
be explained by solar-power absorption.
X-Ray vision?
A further manipulation of Superman’s bio-electric
aura that allows him to perceive cosmic radiation
bouncing off objects in his surrounding environment.
Genius level intellect?
Yellow sun has further enhanced the Man of
Steel's extra-terrestrial biology to process
information faster than his Kryptonian ancestors
(and much faster than humans).
No doubt, comic book writers have presented
other explanations for Superman’s abilities;
yet few offer such a convincing package.
Now, if only there was a definitive answer
for how the Man of Steel can shave his beard?
What do you think of our theory, have a different
interpretation?
Share your theories in the comment section,
and remember to subscribe to our channel for
more videos likes this one.